so I think the topic of platforming is
is pretty interesting
um like what's your view on uh
platforming controversial people let's
let's start with the uh the old would
you interview Hitler
on your podcast and how would you talk
to them oh and follow-up question would
you interview him in 1935
uh 41
and then like 45 well we have an uncanny
valley problem with respect to this
issue of
whether or not to speak to bad people
right so if a person is sufficiently bad
right if they're all the way out of the
valley
then you can talk to them and it's just
it's totally unproblematic
to talk to them because you don't have
to spend any time signaling to your
audience that you don't agree with them
and if you're interviewing Hitler you
don't have to say listen I just got to
say before we start I don't agree with
the whole you know genocide thing and
you know I just think you're uh killing
you know killing mental patients and
vans and all that all that was all bad
as a bad look
Adolf uh you see you just it can go
without saying that you don't agree with
this person and you're not platforming
them to signal boost their
their views you're just trying to if
they're sufficiently evil you can go
into it very much as an anthropologist
would
uh just you just want to understand the
nature of evil right you just want to
understand this phenomenon like how is
this person who they are right
um and that strikes me as a
intellectually interesting and
and morally necessary thing to do right
so yes you I think you always interview
Hitler
when you know once he's hit but when do
you know it once he's legitimately but
when do you know it is genocide really
happening yeah yeah 42 43. if you're on
the cusp of it where it's just he's
someone who's gaining power and you
don't want to you don't want to help
facilitate that
um then there's a question of whether
you can you can undermine him in while
pushing back against him in that
interview right so there are people I
wouldn't talk to just because I don't
want to give them oxygen and I don't
think that in the in the context of my
interviewing them I'm going to be able
to to take the wind out of their sails
at all right so it's like for whatever
either because in asymmetric Advantage
because I just know that they can
do something that they they within the
span of an hour that I can't that I
can't correct for sure you know is it's
like they can they can light many small
fires and it just takes too much time to
put them that's more like on the topic
of vaccines for example having a debate
on the efficacy of vaccines yeah okay
it's not that I don't think sunlight is
usually the best disinfectant I think it
is you know even these asymmetries aside
I mean there are there it is true that a
person can always make a mess faster
than you can clean it up right but still
their debates worth having even given
that limitation
um and they're the right people to have
those specific debates and there's so
certain topics where you know I'll
debate someone just because
I'm the right person for the job and it
doesn't matter how messy they're going
to be I it's just it's just worth it
because I can make my points land at
least to the right part of the audience
so some of it is just your own skill and
competence and also interest in
preparing correctly well yeah yeah in
the nature of the subject matter and and
uh
but yeah but there are other people who
just by default I would say well there's
no reason to give this guy a platform
and there are also people who are so
confabulatory that
they're making such a mess with every
sentence
uh that you in so far as you're even
trying to interact with what they're
saying
you're going to you're by definition
going to fail and you're going to seem
to fail
to an unsufficiently large uninformed
audience where it's going to be a net
negative for for the for the cause of
truth no matter how good you are so like
for instance I think
talking to Alex Jones on any topic for
any reason is probably a bad idea
because I just think he's he's just
neurologically wired
to just I mean utter a string of
sentences he'll get 20 sentences out
Each of which has to be Each of which is
you know contains more lives than the
last
and
there's just there's not time enough in
the world to run down and certainly not
time enough in the span of a
conversation to run down each of those
leads to to bedrock so as to falsify it
and they'll just make up I just and
or and or makes it up and then then
weave it in with with you know half
truths and and and micro truths that
give some semblance of credibility to
somebody out there I mean apparently
millions of people out there
um and there's just no way to to
untangle that in real time with him I
have noticed that you have an allergic
reaction to
confabulatorization yeah confabulation
confabulation that if somebody
says something a little micro untruth
it really stops your brain here I'm not
talking about micro untruths I'm just
talking about making up things out of
whole cloth just like is it if someone
says something like well what about and
then then the thing they put
at the end of that sentence is just a
set of pseudo facts right that you can't
possibly authenticate or not in the span
of that conversation
they will you know whether it's about
UFOs or anything else right
they will seem to make you look like an
ignoramus when in fact everything
they're saying is specious right whether
they know it or not I mean there's some
people who are just crazy there's some
people who are
who are just bullshitting and they're
not even tracking whether it's true it
just feels good and then some people are
consciously lying about things but don't
you think there's just a kind of jazz
Masterpiece of untruth that you should
be able to just wave off by saying like
well none of that is backed up by any
evidence it's just almost like take it
to the humor place and then but the
thing is is the place I'm familiar with
doing this and not doing this is is um
on specific conspiracies like 9 11 truth
right like the 911 so I because of my
because of what 911 did to my
uh intellectual life I mean it's really
just you know it it sent me down a path
for the better part of a decade like I
became a Critic of religion
when I don't know if I was ever going to
be a Critic of religion right like but
that like it happened to be in my
wheelhouse because I spent so much time
studying religion
uh on my own and I was um also very
interested in in the the underlying
spiritual concerns of every religion and
so I was I was um
you know
I devoted
more than a full decade of my life to
just you know what is what is real here
what is possible what is what is the
nature of subjective reality and how
does it relate to reality at large and
is there anything to
you know who just who was someone like
Jesus or Buddha and are these people
frauds or are they are they are this
just uh these just myths or or or is
there really a Continuum of of insight
to be had here that is interesting so I
spent a lot of time on that question
through my 20 the full decade of my 20s
and that was launched in part by 9 11
truth or no but then when 9 11 happened
I had spent all this time reading
religious books to understand
empathically understanding the
motivations of religious people right
knowing just how fully certain people
believe what they say they believe right
so I took religious convictions very
seriously
and then people started flying planes
into our buildings and I so I knew that
there was something to be said about
allegedly the the core doctrine of Islam
exactly
so so I went down so that was that
became my wheelhouse for a time
um you know terrorism and and jihadism
and related topics and so the 911 truth
conspiracy thing kept you know uh
getting aimed at me
and
the question was well do I do I want to
debate these people right yeah like Alex
Jones perhaps yeah I mean yeah so Alex
Jones I think was an early purveyor but
although I don't think I knew who he was
at that point
um
and so and privately I had some very
long debates with people who you know
the one person in my family went way
down that rabbit hole and I just you
know every six months or so I'd
literally I'd write the two-hour email
you know that would try to
try to deprogram them you know however
ineffectually and
uh so I went back and forth three years
on that topic with with in private with
people but I could see the structure of
the conspiracy I could see the nature of
of of of of how
of how impossible it was to
to play whack-a-mole sufficiently well
so as to so as to convince anyone of
anything who was who was
not seeing
the
the problematic structure of that way of
thinking I mean it's not actually a
thesis it's a it's a proliferation of
anomalies that don't you can't actually
connect all the dots that are being
pointed to they don't connect in a
coherent way there's they're
incompatible
Theses that are not and their
incompatibility is not being
acknowledged
um but they're they're running this
algorithms of things or things are never
what they seem there's always malicious
conspirators doing things perfectly that
we we see all we see evidence of human
incompetence everywhere else no one can
tie their shoes you know expertly
anywhere else but over here
people are perfectly competent they're
perfectly concealing they like the
thousands of people are collaborating
you know inexplicably I mean
incentivized by what who knows they're
they're collaborating to murder
thousands of their neighbors and no one
is breathing a peep about it no one's
getting caught on up on camera no one's
you know no one's breathed the word of
it to a journalist
um
and
so
I've I've dealt with that style of
thinking and I've I know what it's like
to be in the weeds of a conversation
like that and and the person will say
okay well but what do you make of the
fact that um all those f-16s were flown
800 miles out to sea on the morning of 9
11 to doing an exercise that hadn't even
been scheduled for that day but it was
and now all of these are I dimly recall
some thesis of that kind but I'm just
making these things up now right so like
that that detail hadn't even been
scheduled for that day it was
inexplicably run that day like so what
how long would it take to track that
down right the idea that this is
anomalous like that there was a f f 16
uh exercise run
on it and it wasn't even supposed to be
run that day right
someone like Alex Jones their speech
pattern is to pack as much of that stuff
in as possible at the highest velocity
that a person can speak and unless
you're knocking down each one of those
things to that audience you appear to
just be uninformed you appear to just
not be you know he didn't know about the
f-16s yeah
um sure he he doesn't know what project
Mockingbird you haven't heard about
project Mockingbird I just made up
project Mockingbird I don't know what it
is but
that's the kind of thing that comes out
tumbling out in a conversation like that
that's the kind of thing frankly I was
worried about in the covet conversation
because not that someone like Brett
would do it consciously but someone like
Brett is swimming in a sea of
misinformation on social living on
Twitter getting people sending the blog
post and the study from
from uh you know the Philippines that
showed that in this cohort Ivermectin
did X right and
and not like
to actually run anything to ground right
you have to actually do the work
journalistically and scientifically
and run it to ground right so many for
some of these questions you actually
have to be a statistician to say okay
they were they used the wrong statistics
in this experiment right now
yes we could take all the time to do
that or we could at every stage along
the way
in a in a context where we we have
experts we can trust go with 97 what 97
of the experts are saying about hex
about the safety of mRNA about the
transmissibility of covet about whether
to wear a mask or not wear masks and I
completely agree that that broke down
uh
unacceptably
in the over the last few years and that
but I think that's largely a social
media and blogs and and the efforts of
podcasters and sub stack writers
were not just a response to that it was
a I think it was it was a symptom of
that and a cause of that right and I
think we're living in a an environment
where
people we basically we have trained
ourselves not to be able to agree about
facts on any topic no matter how urgent
right what's what's flying in our Sky
you know what is you know what is what's
happening in Ukraine is is Putin just uh
denotsifying Ukraine I mean like they're
people who we respect
who are spending time down that
particular Rabbit Hole like this is
this is you know maybe there are a lot
of Nazis in Ukraine and that's the real
problem
right maybe Putin's
maybe Putin's not the bad actor here
right how much time do I have to spend
empathizing with Putin to the point of
thinking well maybe Putin's got a point
and it's it's like what about the
polonium and the nerve agents and the
killing of journalists and the you know
navalny and like
does that count well no listen I'm not
paying so much attention to that because
I'm following all these interesting
people on Twitter and they give me some
Pro Putin material here and there is a
there are some Nazis in Ukraine it's not
like there are no Nazis in Ukraine how
am I going to weight these things
I think people are being driven Crazy by
Twitter yeah but you're you're kind of
speaking to conspiracy theories that
pollute everything and then but every
every example you gave is kind of a bad
faith
style of conversation but but it's not
necessarily knowingly bad faith by I
mean the people the people who are who
are worried about Ukraine Ukrainian
Nazis
to my I mean they're some of the same
people they're the same people who are
worried about
Ivermectin got suppressed like
Ivermectin is really the Panacea but it
got suppressed for because no one could
make billions on it
um
it's the same it's literally this in
many cases the same people and the same
efforts to to unearth those and you're
saying it's very difficult to have
conversations with those kinds of people
what about
uh conversation with Trump himself would
you do a podcast with Trump
no and I don't think so I don't think
I'd be learning anything about him it's
like with with Hitler and I'm not
comparing Trump to Hitler but Clips guy
is your chance you got this one with
certain world historical figures
um
I would just feel like okay this is an
opportunity to learn something that I'm
not going to learn I think Trump is
among the most superficial people we
have ever laid eyes on right like he is
he is in public view right and
I'm sure I'm sure there's some distance
between who he is in private and who he
is in public but it's not going to be
the kind of distance that's going to
blow my mind
um and I think
so I think the liability so for instance
I think Joe Rogan was
very wise not to have Trump on his
podcast
I think all he would have been doing is
is he would have put himself in a
situation where he couldn't adequately
contain the damage Trump was doing and
he was just going to make Trump seem
cool to a whole new
you know potentially new cohort of his
massive audience right
um
I mean they would have had a lot of
laughs Trump's funny
I mean the
entertainment value of things is so
uh influential
I mean it was that one debate where
Trump uh you know got a massive laugh on
the you know his line only Rosie
O'Donnell right
the truth is we're living in a political
system where if you can get a big laugh
during a political debate you win
does this matter who you are like that's
the level of of you know it doesn't
matter how uninformed you are it doesn't
matter that half the debate was about
what the hell we should do about about
uh
you know a threat of nuclear war or
anything else
um
it's we're monkeys right and we like to
laugh